la biodiversité c'est comme un avion les
aides l'avion sont tenus par des rivets
et à un certain moment donné on était en
vol l'on perd un rivet l'avion vole
encore on en perd un deuxième puis
l'avion vole encore il ya un certain
moment donné on va perdre un prix
l'élevage
quelle est cette espèce lokéo leur rôle
important pour que tout le système se
tiennent bien
les caribous sont attachés aux vieilles
forêts puisqu'il y trouve la quiétude
loin des autres prédateurs et lorsqu'on
change la structure du paysage qu on
convertit les forêts matures qui sont
favorables auquel il vend des jeunes
forêts qui sont davantage favorable à
l'orignal ou du cerf de virginie à
l'ours et hulu en génère des pièges
écologique bien sûr dans une forêt
récemment coupé de la nourriture à
profusion mais si tous les compétiteurs
elle a cherché les prédateurs suivent
série nécessaire le caribou réussiront
pas à semer en plus à la voirie
forestière augmente la capacité de
déplacement facilite les déplacements
des prédateurs et leurs patrons chasse
ainsi que leur accès au karibe donc dans
un secteur qui a été récolté les
caribous trouve de moins en moins
d'habitants où ils peuvent se séparer
spatialement des prédateurs cm2 des
populations qui décline l'érosion
actuelle la biodiversité se pensait
rythme les frères on parle de plusieurs
millions d'individus qui meurt
dans une multitude d'espèces autour du
globe au cours des dernières années des
dernières décennies puis dans la
quasi-totalité dès qu'on peut faire des
liens étroits avec l'activité humaine
sur la planète
je pense qu'une grosse partie de cette
problématique là et vient de d'une
conception un peu biaisée de ce qu'on
appelle le développement durable de
longtemps pensé que le développement
durable ici trois pôles d'un triangle
social environnemental et économique
cette recette là pas vraiment bien
fonctionné puisque à travers les années
l'equilibre c'était vous êtes un
compromis sur le plan environnemental
fonctionne mal le vrai développement
durable c'est d'avoir trois cercles
concentriques le plus grand que
l'environnement est ce qu'il peut nous
donner un dr duquel on met un cercle
sociétal qui est plus petit et cette
société-là doit prospérer avec ce que
l'environnement peut lui fournir à
chaque année puis à l'intérieur de ce
cercle c'est à l'abbaye un cercle
économique que l'on peut produire la
richesse sans compromettre les acquis
sociaux et le bien-être la société à
l'intérieur des marges ce que
l'environnement peut nous donne c'est
une vision qui a porté beaucoup
popularisé du développement durable
c'est probablement celle qui est la plus
crédible ou à tout le moins la plus en
équilibre
puisque les compromis se font pas au
détriment de l'environnement conserver
l'habitat du caribou seront peut-être
nous aider non pas juste a conservé de
caribou a conservé une espèce qui est un
rôle clé dans le système puisque si on
perd cette espèce l'eau et des fonctions
écologiques monde et rei
[Musique]